but buddy but even if it woulda skippity
but it would've been better boo I'm a
bitty pie sorry welcome to the why the
greatest show of all time not to be
confused with love why Orla why check
out the G fuel cup I don't I don't have
it today we're in sin let's just get
into the G memes that's all I want to do
me and the boys and when the teacher
asks for it strong kids to put the
chairs away I think I did this once and
I agree I never felt more powerful in my
life some people will never know true
power in this world yeah they're doing
construction I don't know I don't know
this is what it is this is life now UK
there's a quarantine also you can't
construction time when I met Felix in
Canada that's so nice why do I pose like
a little anime schoolgirl what's wrong
with me can't wait to get roasted for
this one look at the riding on boots for
shirt no impossible
it says crises if I had more time I'd
study my ass off more times you gotta
love that argument Tiger Woods is pretty
good at golf whatever but like if I
played as much as he did I'd probably be
still as good if only I play it as money
if only I practice enough yeah yeah keep
doing what you're doing your dude you're
great Ferb I know what we're gonna do
today I'm gonna tell mom what is this
garbage on my subreddit can it stop
already
it never stops make it stop muds do
something don't bother I don't like that
sound
it's like strangling a toad or something
how do you know that sound
answer me cat okay understand it was a
rubbery sound listen I miss sleeping
more than anyone do you not understand I
think about him every single day
he's just set up there and do nothing I
think he died from depression I'm not
gonna lie behold the pewds won't get in
Nate stop it I get it I see what it is
this is markiplier and this is
jacksepticeye I know it don't even
pretend that I don't know hot girls hair
reveal okay okay okay Oh oh damn that's
a good Photoshop that's surprisingly
unnerving big PP men are always quiet
damn Jack goddamn I didn't know the
Irish hunt they just bred differently
devs fixing bugs that players use abuse
or find useful
devs fixing bugs that have been known
for months that break the game forever
yes stupid devs have dare they
racist slowly sacrifice their lives
because of your mistakes oh my god
this reminds me of a dream I had I was
talking to Marta saying she was drawing
with a regular pen I don't know what
it's called in English the one you can
erase the type of pens II can erase
right but this one was a special one of
that type I know I do know dreams aren't
interesting I know but listen to me this
one was made of that but you still
couldn't erase it and I was so shocked
by him like that's the dumbest thing
I've ever seen what's the point of this
then anyway society we live in it what
type of redditor hurt you
people who upvoted but don't post
someone who is a hero for fun yeah
that's gotta be like you know what does
give a shout-out to the people that
click the upload button and download
button alright I'm not gonna do it
though out of respect three year old me
who don't know how to play the game my
good mate well done piers thinking he's
gonna 10 flippin oh well god damn it
this is the problem with the internet I
can't be good at anything anytime I try
anything people are like oh yeah you
think you're good oh look at me oh yeah
you try to speak Japanese you sound like
a stinky blinky oh my god
ethnicity estimate this is what happens
when there's too much duolingo in Sweden
I've been trying to explain to you guys
so guys we did it
PewDiePie is now a verified artist thank
you thank you there might be more music
coming soon
Dave hasn't posted anything in a while
what could that mean smash like on this
video if you would like more music
because I'm mine all day what it's this
meme this is so weird
young pewds getting ready to whoa damn
that's cool
oh my god out of all things I've said
online
I said season one wasn't that good and I
would have skipped that if I known and I
never seen people being so upset over
anything anything I'm sorry it was good
I'm glad I watched it okay I swear I
love it I love Big Brother I swear
me after being spotted in proppant is
that what people are doing now stay
inside and wash your pee-pee stop this
stop going outside I don't know if you
notice but boots usually takes a day off
when saying Thursday he uploaded on
those days to keep us happy during
difficult times thank you but that's so
sweet
finally I got recognized big peepee
click pick something nice huh it's
nothing nice for what oh my god what
let's confuse Pitts with an old pic
That's not me is it I always used to be
the goalkeeper because I hated
soccer or football oh my god the shirt
his ring is from a soccer club known as
Borussia Mangala [ __ ] Bosh all
right well that's not me I'm pretty sure
I wasn't grown up in borussia whoa
that's so cool I don't play minecraft
I'm not the nerd no bye oh my god dad
I'm so excited to play more Minecraft
apparently there's there's a new mind
sing the nether as well and I miss
nether right
I got a billion comments about it
apparently super hard to get neither
right and I walked right past it I
thought it was food it's been really fun
doing more a gameplay stuff I hope you
guys enjoyed - I know there's been a lot
of I'm worried I upload too much I'm
thinking if I should maybe upload them
somewhere else or I don't know I just
like it okay oh my god and here we go
again
god damn it god damn it when you think
2020 can't get any worse but then spoon
guys we had a funeral it's oh it's over
all right we don't talk about it anymore
brah thank you thank you for an amazing
fan all right that's so good
this is me before Akari got video that's
so dope getting ready for Jojo week a
week it's Jojo week
Jojo videos coming out every single day
there's gonna be Jojo videos and then
Jojo videos and then yo your videos and
enjoy yo yo your videos it's gonna be
hella flippin dippin's finger legging
taters squishing poopd pixel experience
to be Simulator pixel X oh god I was so
off manga anime that mean but still made
me laugh
good job apology for poor English when
were you when Felix new vid got priory
but I was sat at home eating pizza and
phone thing new Felix Vida private no
there that's so sad
this is a new version of green text that
is very sad I'm sorry I'm sorry
I realized it was too late to publish a
bit in a video and they yeah and then I
uploaded three videos in one day instead
you could say I'm am I'm pretty good at
YouTube I know what I'm doing two videos
on two days no no no three videos in one
day yeah took 500 years to draw that is
sick I got distracted by the title
goddamn that's sick dude god damn look
at that
well done I don't know what this is
subnautica it's this Jojo it's just full
metal oh it's full metal alchemist 19
year olds when they post something that
feel is pain as soon as the quarantine
ends pain I will come for you I will be
alive in 2018 no I will not
this whole summer in here let's be real
tight this is so sad Pete if I will go
by by 2020 May 20 is when I say bye-bye
right that's really soon got you up
we will rebuild him stronger more
powerful than you can ever believe are
we going to forget the time when piers
to look like Draco Malfoy please do
please forget I don't know why it keeps
changing style normal people just find a
look that looks good on them and stay
with it at least for more than a month
please Felix stop it no one people who
babe I cracked nice
waiter kids under 10 III dad my son just
turned nine yesterday me actually I'm
sixteen
why do you do that as a child what's
wrong with kids oh my god
oh why do I always the why do we always
see cow skulls in the desert and why do
you only see the skull the the body died
somewhere else it makes no sense that's
actually true that's some great
commentary about comics an anime
petition for kids to wear green pants in
half-life Alex series so it looked like
he has no legs dude why would I do that
when the CGI is already costing me banks
dude I'm not making any money or those
episodes which is actually true because
I keep I'm swearing what is it god damn
it what is the biggest way quickest way
to get rid of a boner scissors thirty
percent of female nine year olds don't
listen in this do not listen do not
listen guy at store submit to here I
need more I can't go out now anymore
store a guy store guy be like I know I
was supposed to tell you something but I
can't remember mom the neighbors get
neighbors dead Weiss is so true this
means that at least some of you are the
neighbor's kid you understand that right
I'm not the neighbors kid absolutely not
but statistically
some of you are neighbors kid I remember
neighbors kid it's like when your mom my
mom was friends with someone and I had
to play with her child and their child
was freaking annoying oh my god here we
go again
goddammit I stopped it zooming pens
spins so I thought I'd share mine oh
that's great but can you flip your
cellphone hi yeah
can you flip your thing can you play
your can you flip your headphones can
you okay that's actually okay it's
impressive alright it's impressive I
hope all my fellow 90 rolls are staying
safe out there I'll be in front of the
lines thank you for your service fellow
9 year old male puppies will
intentionally let the female pups win
when they play so that females will keep
playing with them it's much like if you
want me to play Animal Crossing gamers
pewds 7 ought to get minecraft I like
both both both hey made a fan out for
pizza not to get serious I hope this
doesn't die in it whoa that's so
atmospheric and comfortable there has to
be a monster in the background hiding
somewhere that's amazing thank you so
much oh my god what is this stop
confusing me I'm not gonna I'm not even
confused I'm annoying
alright I'm annoyed you've it's just
actually annoying me you took away my
glorious moment of the week you will
soon be involved in many gatherings and
parties no I don't think I will
so I'm not again minecraft terraria man
of Madden I finished it it's up on the
seer its up on my channel I finished it
I finished it the ending was very
lackluster and I finished it when you
make a meme with a bad word so side
we'll have to edit it out and pretty
fine sorry side component side comment
aside I like that that's catchy I'm
going to tell mom oh my god what stop
stop it
the blonde girl was so basic that if you
drop her in acid it's simply balanced
and maim people who post spoilers have
some not to get people who down with
those posts PewDiePie I actually have
not seen a single spoiler what the hell
I didn't even know there was a story
there's a story I love the comments on
this video she was making fun of guys
who post pics with their with a fish and
also be like I just need I'd collect
quarters over that room like oh yeah
that's so much cooler Earth just lost
his best defender it's fine I just have
a cold guys it's just a flu bruh JRPGs
be like chapter one go find cat chapter
for that good me we have killed God guys
we did it nobody can stop this man
laughs that is not real how do you do
that someone stop this man he has
returned more stronger than ever before
he's creating an army deep spend all of
them just got it oh god oh god
thanks.thanks me please here's a pic
Felix can get might same Felix in Lego
also he doesn't have legs and hair I
hope he sees it I saw it and thank you I
understand
I totally understand I get it I totally
get it I totally get it
I get it when you click on a link on the
internet and you see this foot you know
you thought if I become really rich I
will buy the rights for this song and I
will copyright it so we never exists so
it never stops it so it stops existing
forever government work from home huge
gifts I'll make four videos in a day
what can I say it's a good time to be a
gamer I hope you like guys to enjoy the
extra content I think I forgot something
if you forgot that it was a gob what
it's gonna be terraria there it is but I
beat the game I be in Terraria I've been
in subnautica I beat
I've beaten them all I've been every
single game there is baby come over me
after masturbating 14 times there's no
people left for this
I like the gia dude as well very nice
reference very nice oh my god fair
I like this maybe it makes me laugh well
dead say I did a little spend I pulled
an all-nighter to finish that's so cute
well then well boys it's lunchtime hope
you guys enjoyed if you did smash like
subscribe we also have subnautica merch
out now for everyone sold we donate $5
to the Austrian foundation clean ocean
clean video game thank you for watching
see you guys bye bye
you know what big peepees do they play
PewDiePie pixel ings of course pixel
ings this creature collecting game I'm
the primary shareholder over a Brazilian
players have downloaded and it's got a
perfect score it's safe to say it's the
most popular game of all time
PewDiePie pixel aims it's awesome deal
with it deal with it
you